let's get to the sunday surprise draft
coming out of week three chris i give
you the first pick no time for trivia we
got a lot to cover here what do you got
well i'm gonna go with the guy we saw
last night and a great game on sunday
night football alan lazard he was one of
the great surprises you're going well
well we know there's a wide receiver
problem in green bay i mean they never
draft receivers for aaron rodgers to
throw do it drives me crazy as you know
devonte adams isn't playing in a pissed
off saints team that came off a loss but
alan lazard
you know him and valdez scaling but
specifically lazard his ability to make
a few big plays in that game unreal i
mean the ball rogers dropped to him you
know the deep one that taurico whacks
poetically about that like basically it
looks like it hit the roof and then we
had that other one deep down the field
where he got tackled at the two or three
yard line but man if he can emerge as
that second guy
and be in that trust tree with rogers
when davonte adams gets back man they're
starting to develop something here a
little bit with other guys they can beat
you with in the pass game
you know one of the narratives out of
minnesota for the first couple of weeks
of the season is they really miss stefan
diggs they have no one to replace stefan
diggs yeah well the guy they drafted in
round one justin jefferson
nine targets seven catches 175 yards a
71-yard catch-and-run that was just
filthy and the way that he
the way that he danced in the end zone
and the arms thrown out and
and and that put the vikings up 24-12 i
mean credited the titans they flipped it
around pretty damn quickly but the
vikings have something in justin
jefferson and they can build on it even
though they're on three now they're not
done yet nobody's done after only three
weeks and jefferson can become
partially a replacement for what they
lost in staphon dicks yeah well yes this
just in draft lsu guys okay because
they're ballers and they love football
and the bright lights and they never
back down from any of those situations
and yeah i mean he is
i love this kid coming out in the draft
you know that mike he was my second
receiver behind cd lamb he can do
everything i mean he could be michael
thomas in the slot but yet like you saw
yesterday he can burn people with
straight speed and breaking tackles and
making people miss so we might see the
start of a superstar here and if i'm
minnesota
i'm starting to just formulate the
passing offense around justin jefferson
and go from there dalvin cook justin
jefferson and we know he got thielen
he'll have his niche but uh jefferson i
think has a chance to be really special
all right um i think the i'm gonna go to
i gotta go out to dallas just with
cedric wilson i mean
who the hell cedric wilson we've been
talking about cd lamb and amari cooper
and michael galp and ezekiel elliott and
all of a sudden cedric wilson for the
dallas cowboys comes on the scene and
he's running all over the field on the
seattle seahawks defense i know a second
year receiver out of boise state but man
it just shows you the talent they got on
that team at the wide receiver position
it's hard for them to get into the
ground and pound want to run type
football team when you have those
weapons i think they got to play to this
but those are six stats yesterday by all
the receivers but five for 107 from
cedric wilson that's another guy
defenses are gonna have to worry about
trying to match up with in this dallas
passing game
yeah they're talking about cooper gallop
and lamb getting a thousand each you got
to put cedric maybe about four guys with
a thousand each the weight that
prescott's been thrown in the last two
weeks 450 and 475 it ain't out of the
question all right i'm going up to
buffalo because your boy blew through
two touchdown passes to tyler croft
tyler croft has been through a lot foot
injuries missed time and fought back and
and uh you know it was uh
nothing spectacular he's wide open on
both catches but the fact that he's on
the field running the pass routes making
the plays and catching the game-winning
touchdown pass in in an epic regular
season contest he needs a little uh
credit and it was a little bit of a
surprise to see him not stefan diggs
with the game-winning touchdown catch
chris yeah no it was it well you know
they're another team that we can throw
in there just like dallas you start to
sit there and start to go wow they got
weapons i mean you're right croft the
other tight end dawson knox we're seeing
single terry out of the backfield and of
course we know the receivers with brown
beasley and diggs is special that way so
they're fun to watch and good for tyler
croft you're right he's been through a
lot good good day for him i'm gonna you
know go to back here to metlife
giant stadium and go with like i'm gonna
pick kind of two guys and i yoke and
mullen here just because hey backup
quarterback nick mullen how is he going
to perform it's been a while since he
had to play meaningful snaps anything
like that who's he going to throw to you
know they got injuries at receiver
they're going to really rely on a rookie
and brandon ayuk to be the guy yeah they
are that was a pleasant surprise i mean
not only was the team's leading receiver
had a huge reverse touchdown you know in
the third quarter like a
19 20 yard touchdown run that way so
that was a pleasant surprise and of
course the way nick mullins played was
pretty damn good i know that's not a
good giants defense but uh in a game
where you you had to question how
effective the 49ers could be banged up
you know and question those two guys
especially they played really well along
with the rest of the 49ers team
last but for me is the entire panthers
organization whoa to go out to la and to
beat the chargers they were up 11 points
in the fourth quarter and the charger
tried to stay to come back this is a
team that just took the chiefs to the
brink
a week earlier on the same damn field
this is the kind of thing that's going
to give this panthers team some some
confidence
as they are in the process of this
rebuild without christian mccaffrey yeah
maybe they're not far away from having
something there in carolina with teddy
bridgewater and company chris
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports